et depuis la fermeture en tout cas des
établissements scolaires il y à un mois
et demi la continuité pédagogique ce
fait a priori en ligne quand ça marche
difficile cependant pour certains élèves
de suivre leurs cours à grigny dans
l'essonne stefano miss ancien champion
de france de judo a offert des
ordinateurs pour que les jeunes puissent
continuer d'étudier reportage estelle
farges avec piotr hasard ce qui
dominique est étudiante en bts banque
bonjour sourire aux lèvres la jeune
femme vient récupérer de quoi étudier
sereinement
donc je vais vous demander de semis en
face de votre nom et donc on revient
l'ordinateur qui est offert par la
société ils ont donc fait vendre
nouvelle merci c'est très important
parce que j'avais du mal à suivre des
cours j'avais du mal à travailler un peu
ce que travaille avec un téléphone c'est
pas pratique
je trouve à l'ordinateur par va vraiment
m'aider comme dominique en tout ils sont
105 jeunes recensés par la municipalité
de grigny dans l'essonne à recevoir
gratuitement un ordinateur sans matériel
sans internet pour certains nombreux
sont les collégiens lycéens ou étudiants
à s'être retrouvés privés d'école
températion un résultat
dans un souci sur la ville dans le cadre
de la quantité ducati vont s'est aperçu
que les enfants des quartiers
prioritaires de grigny pour certains
n'avaient pas accès à internet d'où la
difficulté d'avoir une quantité
éducative et de suivre leur scolarité
comme c'est le cas à l'heure actuelle en
ces temps de confinement et donc du coup
il a fallu qu'on trouve une solution
la solution est arrivé par cet homme
stéphane nos miss l'ancien champion de
france de judo aujourd'hui chef
d'entreprise a créé une fondation pour
combattre la fracture numérique
notamment en afrique
aujourd'hui c'est donc à grigny là où il
a grandi qu'il s'est mobilisée la
fracture numérique elle et elle est à
côté de paris même des fois dans paris
et donc j'ai décidé d'aider de reporter
mon action d'afrique sur la france pour
bien aider le plus possible d'enfants
qui étaient dans la dans la précarité
scolaire tout part de l'éducation quoi
si les enfants sont bien éduqués après
le la vie allait bien et mieux tracer
quoi et qui soit en échec
déjà c'est difficile de lui dans les
quartiers et là que tu les retrouves en
héros encore plus en échec scolaire a et
discute des carrément déscolarisés parce
que le gamin le gamin qui a qui cas pas
d'ordinateur il est déscolarisé ça c'est
inadmissible en france à voir les gamins
déscolarisés quoi via sa fondation et
son entreprise stefano miss a aussi
lancé une cagnotte en ligne pour
permettre à d'autres enfants de recevoir
un ordinateur